President Trump will meet Russian
President Vladimir Putin for the very
first time this morning on the sidelines
of an international summit in Hamburg
Germany ahead of that meeting mr. Trump
tweeted this I look forward to all
meetings today with world leaders
including my meeting with Vladimir Putin
much to discuss the president's highly
anticipated meeting with his Russian
counterpart is overshadowing day one of
the g20 summit mr. Trump came to Hamburg
after leveling some of his strongest
criticism of Russia so far earlier
police with water cannons drove away
protesters trying to block access to the
summit location major Garrett is
traveling with the president in Hamburg
major good morning good morning
president Trump's encounter with the
Russian president will surely grab
global headlines but it may not change
the frosty relationship between
Washington and Moscow this g20 summit is
all about economic global cooperation
something mr. Trump is undeniably
skeptical of but that cooperation
continues and it is taking new forms
president Trump and German Chancellor
Angela Merkel held private talks before
the summit the White House said they
focused on North Korea Qatar and Ukraine
no mention of Merkel's top agenda items
with the u.s. climate change trade and
NATO the president arrives having
already cancelled multi-nation trade
talks with Europe and Asia even so Japan
and the European Union used the g20
stage to announce their own trade pact
signaling a post US trade dynamic in
both regions mr. Trump's meeting with
Russian President Vladimir Putin has no
set agenda the White House has said
nothing about protesting Russian
meddling in the 2016 election it could
have been a lot of people interfered in
Warsaw yesterday the president disagreed
with the intelligence community's
assessment Moscow was solely to blame I
think it could very well have been
Russia but I think it could well have
been other countries top Senate
Democrats sent a letter to mr. Trump on
the eve of the meeting warning failure
to confront Putin over election
interference quote would be a severe
dereliction of the duty of the office to
which you were elected
News has learned that mr. Trump and
Putin will be joined by US Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson and Russian Foreign
Minister Sergei Lavrov Tillerson has far
more experience than mr. Trump in
dealing with Putin having negotiated
regularly with the Russian leader and
top Russian ministers while CEO of
ExxonMobil for the first time yesterday
the president criticized Russian
intervention in Ukraine calling it
destabilizing for their part Putin and
his team are famous for intense
preparation and diplomatic gamesmanship
a recent example Russian state media
snapping these pictures of a jovial
encounter between President Trump and
top officials in the Oval Office in May
Geof major Gerrits at the g20 summit
thank you